[Music]
grown-up fans of pirates of the
caribbean may have noticed a few strange
things about this swashbuckling
franchise what's up with will and
elizabeth how did jack become a captain
who is styling all those beards keep
watching for all this and more
a ship without a captain is little more
than a mindless pile of driftwood in the
cutthroat days of the age of piracy a
ship needs particular guidance
especially for its daft crew members who
can easily succumb to superstition and
scurvy the most notable captain in the
pirates of the caribbean series is of
course the one and only captain jack
sparrow johnny depp brought the
character to life in all five movies
displaying and acting savvy that let's
face it pretty much carried the series
you are without doubt the worst pirate
i've ever heard of
but you have heard of me
depp's turn as jack sparrow is one for
the aegis it entertained the kids made
the adults feel like kids and indirectly
reminded everyone that keith richards is
somehow still alive that being said by
the fifth film in the franchise adults
might find themselves looking past
depp's performance and asking why do any
of these pirates even follow jack
pirates are a superstitious bunch of
course so it makes sense that jack would
be able to prey on their childish minds
with his powers of manipulation that's
his only real power as a leader though
his ability to spin his self-serving
aspirations into a palatable mission
statement for everyone on board beyond
that he runs away from basically every
confrontation and frequently throws his
friends to the wolves with his only
sense of direction coming from a compass
that usually points to the rum bottle
surely a gentleman a fortune could find
a better boss than jack
the pirates franchise begins in what
appears to be the early 18th century
that said it all takes place in a
fantasy land in which you can sail off
the edge of the world and end up in the
afterlife so the wet of it all probably
isn't too crucial whenever it is they
still make ships out of wood and water
operates the same as it does in our
reality unless there's a ship carrying a
main character during a battle that is
then the wood will regenerate or water
will wash innocently over shredded hulls
outright refusing to follow the laws of
physics it's unlikely that kids are
thinking about ship engineering and
structural integrity in the middle of
climactic battle sequences of course but
adults may be wondering why the heck
these wooden death traps won't just sink
on multiple occasions ships pummel each
other with a barrage of cast iron
projectiles ripping holes from ports to
starboard stop
despite their hulls being transformed
into swiss cheese most of these ships
still manage to sail away in decent
working order they only ever take on
enough water to force a bit of a high
step while below deck unless it's a ship
whose demise is meant to serve the plot
in which case they plunge into the sea
in a matter of seconds the pirates of
the caribbean mythos is vast indeed but
one thing that's never addressed is what
master craftsmen assemble these
remarkable invincible ships
swirling beards and tight dreads are a
mandatory aesthetic for the pirates of
the pirates franchise the merchants of
tortuga must receive regular shipments
of dapper dan pomade so that pirates can
trade gold doubloons for the tools
necessary to maintain their sex appeal
at sea that is the only explanation at
least as to how the mustachioed treasure
seekers keep their facial hair in check
despite those long voyages across the
oceans jack sparrow's mustache always
remains at the perfect length flirting
with unkempt but never out of control
even his usual first mate gibbs sports
some nicely manicured mutton chops for
most of his travels indeed it actually
looks like gibbs somehow finds the time
to run a comb through those gnarly roots
there's nothing wrong with giving your
face some tlc of course it's just
interesting that these men so scornful
of social decorum would be so apt to
maintain visually pleasing face threats
still at least they're teaching the kids
a little something about the value of
self-maintenance
the shortest distance between two points
is a straight line or at least that's
what fundamental physics lessons have
taught us those lessons mentioned
nothing about inverting your ship at the
moment of the green flash to cross into
another plane of reality of course but
the fundamentals are still there when
sailing on the open sea you are able to
travel directly to your destination but
so is everyone else with a ship so how
is it that among the near infinite
vastness of the ocean all these ships
are able to track each other down so
efficiently on a number of occasions in
the pirates franchise a ship will set
off in pursuit of another sometimes days
after their target is left lagging
departure is of no consequence
apparently because they catch up with
them in no time even in the open ocean
the mind of a kid will see sounds logic
they are going where they are going so
of course they will see each other any
adult with any inkling as to how vast
the ocean is however may have some
qualms as to the accuracy of navigation
among the pirates of the caribbean
what is a great disney epic without a
tale of love woven into the fantasy in
pirates of the caribbean the
heartstrings are pulled with a
never-ending sense of melancholy by
elizabeth swann and will turner the
first film offered a cute love story
that led to a doomed wedding at the
beginning of dead man's chest shortly
after those developments though this
relationship unraveled adults will be
quicker to see the cracks of course and
might have noticed that these two hardly
even spend any time together throughout
the second and third films will and
elizabeth's communication is basically
non-existent they refuse to tell each
other anything about their feelings
whatsoever every omission of truth
angers the other in a vicious cycle that
teeters on toxicity in the third
installment in the franchise will looks
at elizabeth and says if you might get
yourself
how can i trust you
which of course is an absurdly
counter-intuitive statement by
definition trusting a loved one means
trusting the decisions they make the two
make a terrible couple for over four
hours of pirates films before they
randomly decide to get married in the
middle of a massive battle in an oceanic
hurricane
swirling around a gaping vortex that
happens to serve as a perfect visual
representation of the relationship
itself kids see two pretty people who
just need to hug it out adults see two
people who don't belong together trying
to force a square block into a round
hole
boxers and wrestlers have the ring mixed
martial arts of the octagon sword
fighters have the entire world
apparently pirates are renowned sword
fighters and likely know that a clash of
steel might occur anywhere at any time
and in any place naturally the
exhilarating soundtrack and audible
clanging of swords is enough to
enrapture the younger audiences
but adults may begin to feel incredulous
by the time a swordfight has broken out
on a giant rolling wheel in the jungle
of course when compared to the
formalities of say fencing the contrast
actually makes a bit of sense
aristocratic sword battles entail a posh
atmosphere complete with dorky outfits
and flat fair ground meanwhile the
rascals of the sea can fight anywhere
even balancing on a sail mass and a
hurricane pirates of the caribbean
stretches credulity for adults with his
over the top and near endless
swordfights but take a cue from the kids
on this one and remember that jack
sparrow is a bonafide legend
by the time the third pirates film rolls
around most of the characters on the
screen have become full-blown
machiavellian schemers each with their
own highly complex machinations at play
some have plans that reach far into the
future like willow barbosa others
stretch as far as grabbing a chest and a
moment of opportunity and running into
the jungle but in order for those more
complex schemes to come together
numerous moving parts must work together
in order for the desired outcome to
present itself now kids will no doubt
get a kick out of watching a miraculous
set of circumstances come together and
form a positive outcome for a hero or a
villain adults however may be wondering
how anything ever works out at all it's
astounding that anybody ever succeeds at
anything in the pirates universe given
that no one ever makes a peep as to
what's a play if a single element and a
character's plan didn't turn out the way
they wanted everything would crash down
in spectacular fashion a simple solution
to this problem might involve being at
least slightly more forthcoming about
your intentions even if only to your
allies but no not for a pirate here the
name of the game is hoping for the best
and proudly accepting the glory when you
accidentally succeed in a plan that
existed nowhere but in your own mind
take notes kids
for the finale of your swashbuckling
pirate themed trilogy you're gonna want
something big something god-like even
the ending moments are the world's end
the caesar pirates of the brethren court
released the goddess calypso apparently
pirates of yore had previously gathered
some trinkets together and used them to
bind the goddess into an earthly form
thus taming the seas themselves
these fabled pirates were so poor
however that they had to use whatever
random stuff they had lying around to
cast the spell aye the original plan was
to use nine pieces of eight to bind
calypso but when the first court met the
brethren was one skint broke
so in order to release calypso at a
later time they had to assemble all
those pieces toss them in a hat and
light them on fire while whispering an
incantation that may be enough to
satiate any child's curiosity but adults
will be wanting to know more once
calypso is unleashed she morphs into a
wave of crabs assumes a celestial form
and takes command of the ocean that
means that calypso we see creating
oceanic maelstroms as the calypso the
pirates and the stories faced how the
heck did a bunch of pirates who were so
poor they had to use junk drawer
contents as their trinkets capture a
goddess sure davey jones clearly
betrayed her and told the pirates how to
bind her but it seems unlikely that you
can just lasso someone with that kind of
power
anyone who has been to a disney
amusement park knows that visiting the
pirates of the caribbean ride is an
essential part of the experience
at disneyland it starts with a gentle
glide through a bio filled with
fireflies and then a gentle dip into the
lower tier to sail through the story
itself most of the ride is a slow trip
through an animatronic song and light
show it features cannonball fights drunk
pirates balancing on barrels parrots and
all sorts of mischievous behavior the
kids get a kick out of it and the
parents can sneak in a quick nap all
good right so how is it that this ride
experience spawned a barrage of films
centered around cursed sea dwellers and
monsters galore it's a pretty big leap
and kudos to the filmmakers for not
putting a cap on the limits of their
imagination without depth jack sparrow
softening the blow with a hearty dose of
comedic gold most of these films would
be the stuff of nightmares sea monsters
undead sharks skeletal pillagers and
weird hair are just a few of the horrors
that the franchise draws from its source
material still the end result is nothing
to be sniffed at
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]